my too tall for most of its history
America's population has been younger
than other nations as a result America
has been a nation of risk takers who
have quickly found prosperity but in
recent years and aging America led
mostly by the baby boomers has made life
more difficult for young Americans as a
result American institutions have
stagnated a population that is aging is
not necessarily alarming but with age
come more invasive and burdensome
regulations in many walks of life in the
cases of housing and employment older
Americans have slowly created policies
that protect their investments whether
it be in property or career stringent
zoning laws and employment credentialing
have caused younger Americans to spend
more time getting dubiously useful
degrees and certifications and taking on
more debt delaying marriage and
childbearing which in turn is making
America even older and more bureaucratic
simply put when the population becomes
less agile so do its foundational
institutions eliminating unnecessary
regulations and barriers in many sectors
would create an America that is stronger
and more prosperous for everyone so what
do you think about this do you think
America's institutions have become more
rigid and inflexible let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI